我叫Farhan Thawar，是Shopify的工程负责人。我想花点时间思考一个问题：随着AI介入并承担了工程师工作中的许多部分，我们现在的工作到底是什么？因为情况确实
发生了巨大变化，尤其是对工程领域，甚至对整个研发部门以及其他学科也是如此。所以我想探讨这个问题。但在探讨之前，我想先花一点
时间默哀一下。这条推文真的让我很触动。这是我们生活中所有软件的顶峰，包括你们中许多人，也包括我自己，我们逐字逐句地编写了这些软件。想想
至今为止的一切都是这样写出来的，真是令人惊叹。所以，让我们默哀片刻，也许还有点想哭，因为这曾是我们做事的方式，而未来我们将不再如此。我想
探讨一下发生了什么变化。如果你看看SDLC，即软件开发生命周期，你会注意到我们花费时间的地方正在转移。所以，看左边的图表，你会看到大部分时间
都花在了编码上。你当然也花时间在规划、验证、测试和维护上，但很大一部分，那个大的蓝色框，是编码步骤。而当你看到右边时，变化的是编码
部分发生了巨大变化，因为你将花更多时间使用工具进行规划和剖析。你可能会花时间验证AI工具的输出，但编码步骤已经大不相同。而且
在编码步骤中，有两类事情要考虑。屏幕上显示的是一种并行编码的概念。也就是说，我要将任务分解成子任务，然后在每个子任务中，我会让AI代理
去执行这些子任务，然后我回来整合并进行某种验证。但还有一种顺序式的、非常深入的，比如批评循环。也就是说，我要真正与一个AI结对。我会深入
地做某件事，使用高推理模型。我可能会让另一个模型来质疑它。但同样，你不再亲自编写代码。你与AI代理合作，你
在努力规划如何为最终客户构建东西。所以事情在变，你如何分配时间也在变。因此问题就是：我们实际的工作是什么？结果发现，你的价值从
那个逐字逐句输入命令到你的编程环境、你选择的IDE和编程语言的人，转变为这些其他方面：品味、判断力、何时应该构建某物？
为什么我应该构建？我应该构建什么？我如何思考将构建的架构？公司通常以不同的方式思考这些。例如，在Shopify，我们有一个单体应用。我们努力将东西
集成到单体中，并努力避免拆分为微服务。其他公司可能会选择不同的方式。那如何融入你的工作流程？当然，理解问题，花大量时间与客户
一起思考问题，也要思考可能的解决方案集。在Shopify内部，我们有这样一句话：当有人向我们提出某件事时，我们可能会说，“那很酷，所以它有效。你如何在10000个
可能正确的解决方案中选择了这个？你是如何想到这个绿色路径方案的？”然后，当然，还有学习。构建软件、与客户合作以及在团队内部工作，真正的一部分是学习过程。我们实际上有一个有趣的故事
关于这一点。在LLM出现之前，我们有一个相当庞大的团队，大约50名工程师在我们的一个项目上工作，他们花了18个月为我们的商家构建了某样东西。我们正准备发布它。我们进行了一次著名的Tobi评审。Tobi是我们的
创始人兼CEO。我们介绍了架构，我们展示了我们构建的一切。我们展示给他，他说，“这很棒。我们应该发布它。”正当我们要离开会议室时，在
我们远程办公之前，他停下来，说，“实际上，问一个问题。如果你们可以重新开始，你们会怎么构建它？”团队停下来，他们说，“嗯。”然后有人走到白板前，说，“嗯，”
以我现在所知的一切，我们会这样构建它。”他描述了一个完全不同的、更简单的架构。Tobi说，“那你们为什么不那样构建呢？”事实上，我们的转变是，他说，“就把你们做的删除，”
重新开始。”因为他试图向我们展示的是，学习才是产物，而不是代码。所以我们做的事情是，我们删除了——实际上我们并没有删除代码，因为那太难了，但我们想出了
一种方式，实际上利用我们所学到的，也就是说，你可以看那段代码，但不能剪切粘贴，因为那是自然倾向。我们在3个月内重建了新系统。结果是，我们有了一个
更简单、更优雅的解决方案，因为学习是产物，而不是代码。所以现在，随着AI在工作流程和SDLC方面的变化，瓶颈是——我不知道大家是否读过这本书，
这是一本非常好的书，一本虚构小说，讲的是工厂里的一个人，他试图优化工厂的各个阶段。实际上发生的是，他去解决一个瓶颈，然后
他解决了那个瓶颈，然后意识到，“天哪，我看着这个工作流程，另一个瓶颈出现了。”于是他接着去解决那个瓶颈，你猜怎么着？另一个瓶颈又出现了。所以正在发生的是，他
他正在优化工厂，寻找瓶颈，然后解决它，再找下一个瓶颈。这正是现在发生的事情。AI 写代码的环节只是
把瓶颈转移到了软件开发生命周期的其他环节。所以当你花时间测试、验证或者写代码的时候，瓶颈会移动，这很正常。你只需要找到解决瓶颈的方法，然后你猜怎么着？
你会遇到下一个瓶颈。而且这个过程会不断重复，但这本书很值得一读。回到我们上一张幻灯片讲的，你的品味和判断力仍然很重要，你仍然为流程带来很多价值。只是瓶颈不同了。
你为流程带来了很多价值，只是面对的是不同的瓶颈。那为什么我们在 Shopify 这么重视这件事呢？我为什么要讲 SDLC？为什么讲 AI？因为实际上我们为全球的商务基础设施提供动力。
我们花了很多时间思考如何构建产品，让别人可以在我们之上进行开发。我们在 Shopify 有一个口号：我们总是努力构建基础设施。举个例子，如果我用两周能开发一个功能，
或者我花两个月建好基础设施，之后就能在一小时内实现同一个功能，那我总会选择后者。这意味着我们专注于基础设施，让我们的开发者和生态系统的开发者都能在此基础上开发。
我们这样做是因为相信未来充满不确定性。如果我们建好了基础设施，我就能在一小时内完成功能开发，那其他人在上面还能做出什么，谁知道呢？
所以这就是我们的关注点。有趣的是，我刚给你举了那个例子，但有了大型语言模型，也许我们不再需要做那种权衡了。如果我的问题定义得足够清晰，
还需要在两周和两个月之间做选择吗？也许两者差不多，因为“clanker”——这是 Toby 喜欢用的词——能写出所有代码。我就不用纠结两周和两个月之间的权衡了。
这里有一些数据，说明我们规模之大。我们也花了很多时间优化基础设施。性能很重要，简洁很重要，韧性很重要，可用性
也很重要。当然，用 AI 写代码也能实现所有这些，只是意味着你花时间的地方会转移。我们在 AI 领域的旅程已经持续了一段时间。
我们在 2021 年成为 GitHub Copilot 的首批用户，比 ChatGPT 早一年。我主要是“说服”了 GitHub CEO 给我们使用权限。这让我们进入了自动补全的时代，你们可能还记得，我开始写一行代码，
然后它会自动补全剩余部分，或者我在文件里写个注释，它就能补全一个函数。这就是和 AI 配对的想法，对吧？这种来回互动，一起构建东西的能力。
我们很快用 ChatGPT 推出了功能，这真的是“AI 半人马”阶段的几年，你有大脑和 LLM，你带它们一起工作，共同构建东西。
当然，2025年发生了什么？Toby 发布了我们称之为“全世界都听到的推文”，说 AI 将成为 Shopify 员工的基本期望。这条推文有趣的地方不在于它最初是内部备忘录，
而是之后 CTO 和 CEO 们纷纷给我发消息，分享他们公司里类似的内部沟通。因为他们想让人们理解的是，我们希望你们
理解如何使用这个工具，我们希望你们具备“AI 反应力”。这是什么意思？AI 反应力意味着你从遇到问题到伸手拿 AI 的距离要非常小。你能多快想起用 AI？
你被问题卡住后，多久能反应过来：“哦，等等，让我用 AI 快速解决。”我们花了很多时间思考 Shopify 的 AI 反应力，写文章，开始分享不同
公司（包括我们）如何在各个领域使用它的方法，不仅仅是工程、产品、研发，而是整个公司。我们有很多例子。我带来 AI 反应力的主要方式之一
是通过 Cursor。我们在 2025 年部署了 Cursor，然后我很快就用光了许可证。我们公司大约 8000 人，我买了 1500 个许可证，结果第一周就用完了。
我觉得最有趣的一点，也是我和 Cursor 分享的是，使用 AI 的不是那些典型的技术岗位。我原本以为会主要是工程师、产品、数据科学家，可能还有设计师。但实际我看到的是
财务、人力资源、销售、市场。他们把 Cursor 当作进入这些代理的窗口。即使他们不看代码，他们也是在用它来和后端 LLM 交互。
所以对我来说，看到这种现象非常有趣。当然，我买了更多许可证，直到几乎整个 Shopify 都在使用这些工具。今天我们有大量的工具，包括
Cursor，人们还用 Pi、Claude Code、Codeax，我们甚至有个内部工具叫 River，它像一个全公司的代理核心，你可以问它问题，
它可以为你写代码。但这只是表明人们有选择，而我们迈向 AI 反应力的第一步就是直接推出 Cursor。那条线显示了内部备忘录出现的时间。
这个规定被取消了。所以，如果你们正在考虑，在公司里，这样的强制规定是否能改变行为？实际上，托比的备忘录出来后，一切就都变了。它极大地改变了Shopify的思维方式。
我们不仅看到了Cursor的使用和这些工具的采用，还看到了实际的使用案例。支持团队构建了一个叫Scout的工具，你可以直接向它询问关于我们收到的反馈的问题。
现在，我们的产品管理团队经常使用它。你随时可以查看商家最不满意的方面。客服团队用Cursor制作月度业务回顾。
季度业务回顾也借助了Cursor。这是一种真正向客户传递信息和洞察的方式。财务团队也构建了预测工具。所以看到不仅仅是工程师在使用我们所构建的东西，我们真的很高兴。
同时，我还想改变公司文化。2024年我们有75名实习生，而2025年和2026年有1000名。带实习生来工作不是为了慈善。
有些人可能会说：“哦，这是社区服务，带他们来对他们有好处，也是很好的经历。”但对我们来说恰恰相反。我们希望他们来教我们如何工作。想想现在的实习生和年轻人。
如今的大学生和刚入行的年轻人，他们生活中有多大比例是与AI共度的？2026年毕业的学生，整个大学生活都有ChatGPT或其他工具相伴。我们想让这些人来到我们的办公室，质疑我们所有的做事方式。
为什么要用这种方式工作？我们希望他们有冲劲、有热情。我们想改变公司文化。所以我们招了1000名实习生，最终也聘请了很多全职加入我们，但这确实是启动文化和变革的绝佳方式。
全职与我们合作，但这也是启动公司文化变革的好方法。不仅仅是强制AI自动反应，还要改变公司的人员构成。而对我来说，关键点在于——这实际上是我发的推文——就是“AI半人马”这个说法。
关键在于，人类和LLM结合可以创造出更好的东西。我非常喜欢“AI半人马”这个说法，我们用了几年，从2021年到2024年、2025年左右。
不幸的是，它没有像我希望的那样持续下去。那段时间很神奇，我们可以与AI配对编程，AI确实需要我们在代码方面提供建议。但，你们知道，在2025年12月，
这一切都消失了。为什么？嗯，人们称其为“奥普斯45”时刻或“GPT-52”时刻。当时，许多世界顶级工程师在圣诞假期说：“我觉得LLM比我更擅长编码。”这就是整个观念——
工程师的伦理就是“天哪，我的工作就是写代码，我生命和工作的全部就是逐字输入机器要执行的机器代码。”
现在，我将成为AI的“人”。因为当LLM比你更擅长编码时，你应该把瓶颈，也就是写代码，转移到流程中的其他环节。这对我们来说是重要时刻。
这是“机器”与“人类”的对决。你必须退后一步，反思自己：“我想把时间花在哪里？”如果AI更擅长写代码，你还要不要写代码？这是一个开放性问题。
有没有一些特定的场景，LLM不擅长，你必须亲自写代码？有可能。但我认为，现在许多公司90%以上的代码应该由AI来写，因为它确实比你写得更好。
在2025年12月之后，2026年开始，我们也开始改变对公司的期望。 “Token最大化”成为了名词，因为现在人们一遍遍地使用token。
由于我们一开始就强调AI自动反应，现在我们希望转向“AI杠杆”，因为现在整个公司都在使用AI。
不仅利用AI来减轻负担，让你专注于你关心的领域，发挥人类的价值和判断力，还有“以懒为荣”的理念。
就像在说：“你知道吗？我五分钟就搞定了这个，以前要五个月。”我们想要示范，为什么来展示可能性。我们当然和其他公司一样，有LLM排行榜。
我们向每个人展示“看我用掉了多少token，我进了前10”。但现在我们转向了“使用仪表盘”，它仍然显示你的token支出以及如何与同行对比，但重点不再是排行榜。
不再是关于“进入前十”，而是关于“提供价值”。有趣的是，你不仅能看到谁使用了最多的token，哪些学科、资历层级或经理与独立贡献者，甚至他们在哪个地区，还有谁使用了最贵的token？
有趣的是，比如“这些人在做推理，他们每百万token的成本更高，而那些只是大量使用token的人。”
Shopify对token没有限制。但我们有“断路器”，这实际上是为了发现是否有失控的代理。我们已经见过这种情况，比如你可能想分析一大段代码，或者……
可能会给一个问题，让智能体跑偏到奇怪的方向。然后你会被叫停。你会收到一条Slack消息说：‘嘿，我们停了你的智能体。你今天花了X美元。你确定还要继续吗？’
人们会说：‘是的，我想继续。’然后我们不会阻止你。你可能会说：‘不，我不想继续了，因为你说得对。我没想过这会花这么多钱或这么多时间，我可以停下来。’但是，除此之外，我们还是处于那种打开工具、让人们用他们想用的东西来达成目标的模式。
有些东西，顺便说一句，随着我们转向AI并没有改变。我之前谈过一些改变的事情。这是没变的：帕金森定律。我最喜欢的定律之一，对吧？基本上就是说，你给某件事多少时间，它就会花多少时间。
如果我要求你周五给我什么，你周五会给我。如果我要求你下周五给我，你下周五会给我。现在，帕金森定律在AI中令人惊叹的是，一切都变了，因为路线图不再会是6个月。通常会变成：‘为什么这个月完不成？为什么这周完不成？为什么今天完不成？’
这种快速原型化的想法，然后拿那个原型早点给客户看，因为你有这些‘打字机’在帮你写代码。这没有你想的那么难，你真的应该重新看看帕金森定律，把所有路线图都缩短。
我们有句话，现在在Shopify我们终于能看到路线图的尽头了，因为我们有了这些工具。还有什么没变？学习。我之前谈过这个。我们专注的一切都是为了尽可能多地学习。
代码不是成果，学习才是成果。你要确保你主动向你的团队提问，你知道，我听到有些人谈论每周发布，我们谈论的是每周学习。
这周你学到了什么？什么是不直观的？什么是你相信而别人不信的‘秘密’，因为你看过数据，你试过原型，你把它放到客户面前。你学到的什么让你下周能做出不同的决定？这个没变。
我喜欢这张图。这是我让AI画一张结对编程的图时得到的。毫无意义，但我觉得很好笑。因为对我来说结对编程就是这样。我想，好吧，不是在一个键盘上，而是在多个键盘上，但结对编程没变。有些事情你会和另一个人一起在电脑前学，还有LLM，但你独自用LLM是学不到的。
是的，你可以用这些‘打字机’来写代码，你会学到一些东西，但有一个聪明的同伴，在规划阶段、验证阶段以及当然编码阶段一起工作，会让学习变得更多。再说一次，别忘了学习是目标。这是结对编程的真实图片。
两个人，一台电脑，通常可能是两个显示器、两个键盘，但理念是两个人朝着同一个目标一起工作。是的，用今天的说法，他们也会有一个LLM。这是我最喜欢的结对编程语录之一，不是要把这个演讲变成关于结对编程，但重点是它不是代码行。从不是代码行。
每次我跟高管说话，他们都会说：‘等等，如果我两个工程师，他们会写得更少。’我说：‘是的，希望甚至更少。’重点根本不是代码行。我觉得很好笑的是，人们看token消耗量或代码行数来判断团队是否高效。
所以，如果你不能用这些，你能用什么？我们通过观察Shopify生态系统，注意到一些东西，我们注意到一些可能有趣的指标，但没有一个，甚至整个集合，都不能用来判断我们是否高效。
每个网络工程师的PR数上升了。这可能不奇怪。整个行业都看到了。我们看到PR的复杂性在上升。所以，每个PR，是的，数量在上升，但每个的复杂性也在上升。我们注意到项目持续时间在下降。所以，我们有一个产品管理系统，我们可以看到在没有其他变化的情况下，项目的持续时间在缩短。
所以，我们也把这个归功于AI。然后更重要的是，项目的雄心在上升。人们尝试的事情，他们想带给客户的东西也在上升，这实际上让我们在思考问题的方式上更有雄心。
我们仍然喜欢每周演示。我们认为这是一个很好的方式，当你总是想知道，当我与高管交谈时，衡量工程速度的最好方法是什么？每周演示。这是看看什么交付给客户的最好方式。然后，不要把地图和领土混淆。这经常发生在我身上。一位高管可能写了一些代码然后展示给你，说：‘看，这多容易。我构建了这个东西，为什么你不能直接部署到生产环境？’
一个原型？原型不是生产。我经常看到这个。别忘了，我有一个会写代码的CEO。他会对我说同样的话：‘等等，我5分钟就构建了这个东西。为什么团队花了一个月？’我说：‘因为原型不是生产级别的代码质量。’这仍然是真的。而且没有改变。但是，原型化是一种获取反馈和尝试新事物的绝佳方式。我们真的，真的尝试。
我们能用什么？所以，我们通过查看Shopify生态系统，注意到了一些东西，我们注意到一些可能有趣的指标，但没有一个，甚至整个集合，都不能用来判断我们是否高效。
每个网络工程师的PR数上升了。这可能不奇怪。整个行业都看到了。我们看到PR的复杂性在上升。所以，每个PR，是的，数量在上升，但每个的复杂性也在上升。我们注意到项目持续时间在下降。所以，我们有一个产品管理系统，我们可以看到在没有其他变化的情况下，项目的持续时间在缩短。
所以，我们也把这个归功于AI。然后更重要的是，项目的雄心在上升。人们尝试的事情，他们想带给客户的东西也在上升，这实际上让我们在思考问题的方式上更有雄心。
我们仍然喜欢每周演示。我们认为这是一个很好的方式，当你总是想知道，当我与高管交谈时，衡量工程速度的最好方法是什么？每周演示。这是看看什么交付给客户的最好方式。然后，不要把地图和领土混淆。这经常发生在我身上。一位高管可能写了一些代码然后展示给你，说：‘看，这多容易。我构建了这个东西，为什么你不能直接部署到生产环境？’
一个原型？原型不是生产。我经常看到这个。别忘了，我有一个会写代码的CEO。他会对我说同样的话：‘等等，我5分钟就构建了这个东西。为什么团队花了一个月？’我说：‘因为原型不是生产级别的代码质量。’这仍然是真的。而且没有改变。但是，原型化是一种获取反馈和尝试新事物的绝佳方式。我们真的，真的尝试。
工程速度？每周演示。这是看看什么交付给客户的最好方式。然后，不要把地图和领土混淆。这经常发生在我身上。一位高管可能写了一些代码然后展示给你，说：‘看，这多容易。我构建了这个东西，为什么你不能直接部署到生产环境？’
分钟。为什么团队花了一个月？’我说：‘因为原型不是生产级别的代码质量。’这仍然是真的。而且没有改变。但是，原型化是一种获取反馈和尝试新事物的绝佳方式。我们真的，真的尝试。
很难删除原型代码，或者干脆不用它，因为那真的是一次探索性的实践，而不是能用于生产的代码。举个例子，我有个实习生删了六行代码，
每年为我们的基础设施节省了超过60万美元。那么，告诉我之前幻灯片里的哪个指标能显示这个实习生很厉害？没有一个。对吧？实际上，我甚至不知道，但我很确定那个实习生那个学期做了很多
其他事情，而不仅仅是这一件，即使只做了这一件事也没问题。所以，真的没法用电子表格来管理。如果你以为有AI就能用电子表格管理，那祝你好运。
所以，我要讲讲我们在Shopify讨论的五个方面，关于我们如何工作，这样大家能有个了解，之后我也很乐意和大家交流你们看到的。第一，模型选择。我们仍然只
允许我们的工程师使用最大、最贵的模型。我们只让他们用Opus 4.5或GPT 5.5，或者Gemini 3.5。我们不允许他们用更小的模型，因为我们相信人的时间
比机器时间更值钱。这意味着，如果人用了小模型，引入了一个小错误，他们得花很多很多小时去找，而用大模型就不会这样。所以，当更大的模型出来时，我们就用，我们
不让人们用更小的模型，至少在工程领域是这样。第二，瓶颈是代码审查。你们可能在我提到瓶颈幻灯片时就已经想到了。大量代码被生成，你怎么审查所有代码？对吧？让我给你看
人类语言中最可怕的四个字母。每个PR都写着这句话，但可能还是有问题，还是可能导致线上事故。太疯狂了。所以，如果你觉得你现在的流程没问题，你说：“我
不能让AI看我的代码。”看看这些字母，你的员工根本没在看代码，他们不擅长这个。所以，你应该做点别的。我们用账户，我会给你们看一张关于LLM委员会的幻灯片，但
我们也用很多其他AI工具来帮助判断这些代码产物是否应该进生产。完美吗？当然不。人完美吗？当然不。现在有人跟我抱怨说：
“天哪，AI审我的代码要一个小时。”我说：“在AI之前，人类给我LGTM不也要24小时或48小时吗？”谁在乎呢？AI更好。AI会更准确。是100%准确吗？
不是。但比人好吗？是的。这里有个例子，看看LLM委员会是什么样的。对吧？这是虚构的，但理念是我们有不同的模型执行不同的任务，它们查看
代码的不同部分，寻找不同的问题。比如这里可以看到可访问性，它们还寻找其他东西。我们用所有这些裁判来决策：“这段代码应该进生产
还是应该带着评论发回？”责任。在Shopify，我们不让AI承担责任。你可以和LLM一起工作，让它写任意多的代码。你当然要做验证，但你的
名字会出现在PR上。你也可以标记你的LLM。酷。但这跟LLM没关系，是跟你有关。责任可以分担，但不能推卸。你的名字在PR上，你的PR进生产。这是一个有趣的话题。如何
考虑招聘？我们还没……那个耸肩的表情是因为我们完全不知道如何为AI招聘。我觉得没人知道。我甚至不知道。实际上，Cursor 著名地不允许你在面试中使用Cursor，所以我不知道
Cursor现在怎么样，但我们肯定还在摸索。不过，我喜欢这个模型，顺便说一句，这是一个有趣的模型，可以用来思考这个问题。我在滑铁卢大学第一年学数学。我们不被允许使用
计算器。所以整个第一年都没用计算器，然后第二年我们有了计算器。这逼得我们用手工学习所有东西。每个人都用手工学习，然后你才能引入计算器。所以，AI有点类似。
如果我们希望人们理解AI的底层部分，我们就要让他们能在没有AI的情况下工作。所以，这是第一点。给他们一个不能使用AI的问题。第二点，AI可选。所以，也许我实际上不能
用AI，或者抱歉，也许我手工做不了，但也许我可以用AI。所以，你可以选择用。最后，AI强制。我给你一个非常大的问题，时间不够，现在你必须使用这个工具。
我认为当你纵观这三个方面，你就能很好地判断一个人是否在这三方面都擅长。但这样会漏掉那些天才，对吧？这就像棋手，他们只是
随便走一步，说感觉不错。会有那样的人，他们能用AI，然后说：“我不懂代码，但我能运用这个工具，得到惊人的结果。”最后，我觉得最搞笑的是
高管们说：“哦，我不能让我的开发团队变小吗？”这是我听到的最搞笑的话。比如：“我们有100个工程师，如果只要10个呢？”我想，这太没野心了。我们反过来想。我说：“我们有3000
个工程师。为什么他们不能像10万人一样？”我们就是这么说的。因为那更有野心。你能做更多，对吧？杰文斯悖论。你让东西更便宜，更容易获得，更多人会用。
我们正在解决创业问题。为什么没有更多创业者？你以为我们会缩小规模？不，我们认为每个人都能更有生产力。甚至有一篇搞笑的博客文章出来，有人写道
这就是Shopify背后那两万三千名工程师的AI布局。我感觉自己已经走了一半，四分之一的路了。对某些人来说，我们好像有两万三千名工程师，太棒了。但我们其实只有三千。我希望有人能写篇文章，说Shopify有十万工程师背后的力量。
我就想让人写篇文章，说Shopify有十万工程师背后的力量。好了，最后总结一下。有些东西变了，有些没变，对吧？AI会写代码、审代码，你得接受这个事实。现实就是这样。
这就是正在发生的事。你应该试着拥抱它。你会花更多时间在生态系统的其他部分，对吧？在软件开发生命周期里，你会花时间在规划上，花时间在验证上。而且你的团队资历构成可能会改变。
我刚招了一千名实习生。顺便说一句，我说服了Cloudflare也招一千名实习生。然后我看到AWS的Matt Garman今年招了一万一千名实习生。各个级别都在变化。你可能会做出不同的决定。
你可能会决定多招中级工程师，或者多招资深工程师。那什么没变呢？品味和判断力。你仍然需要关注品味和判断力，关注你交付给用户的东西。而且你会有更多时间花在这上面，因为你可以更深入地研究问题。
你可以深入问题，所以有更多时间投入。衡量工程绩效仍然很难，这一点不会改变。你不能用电子表格来管理，也不能突然就说：“嘿，我们找到了公式。”
就像销售人员，衡量标准就是他们能卖多少。但工程师呢？衡量标准是什么？我觉得没有一个指标。最后也是最重要的一点，学习仍然是目标。所以，对于那些想管理工程团队的人，别只看表面成果。
别只看代码，别只看交付。关键是学习的速度有多快。因为你可以用这些工具，随心所欲地快速构建任何东西。非常感谢。
谢谢大家。